it seems like a very colorful group of
characters to randomly be on an elevator
with oh great this is going Armin your
elephant good hi
listen your elevator seems to be stuck
you folks sit tight and we'll have you
out in a minute
Wow great now what do we do if I got
these stories I do it's about how I plan
to take over the world by creating one
monster at a time instead of building an
army of that and how I was
embarrassingly defeated by a martial
arts version of please cries you must
have some interesting tales well I did
write a screenplay
you wrote a screenplay yeah I write
every morning at Starbucks I justify
that rewards card somehow well it's
about a bunch of people trapped in an
elevator
wow I love it already but one of them is
a killer and well the power is faulty so
every time the lights go out the killer
strikes yeah so basically the race is on
to rescue a whole bunch of
claustrophobic people trapped inside an
elevator before the lights go out again
and the killer picks them off one by one
yeah this is its Cthulhu
okay well that's really dumb because you
had this ingenious idea for a setup
building suspense and drama downright
heads captain then you hook it all up by
throwing in something supernatural for
no reason it doesn't matter it doesn't
fit until that's died emphasize it
doesn't matter
they already did something like that M
night Shyamalan movie devil
Wow Shamblin only worked on the story it
has its fingerprints all over it it's
got the hokey actin I hope it writing
the hokey twist it's got every hokey
thing but the Hokey Pokey but to his
credit he does represent my work would
know really the guy who claimed
represent Nickelodeon cartoon represents
the most evil demonic force on earth hey
I got an idea
while we're working on breaking you out
why don't I play the movie to keep you
entertained I'm sorry you cut out there
could you say that again
still didn't get it tell you what go
ahead and watch the movie until we can
figure out a way to hear you back I
guess this is devil it's really not that
bad
so our film begins with a logo that
reads a knight chronicles and then the
number one hey this was the first fit of
series of films that Shyamalan was
supposed to work on whoa why aren't
there more because the first one was
devil and because Shyamalan can never
start a movie without important-looking
text here's some important looking text
ah now this is especially essential
without it I don't think we could ever
draw the conclusion that the devil is
bad really all these years and that's
never come across I need to make more
Republicans and just listen to how the
music tries to scare you into what I
guess is supposed to be a big reveal
oh fuck all the possibilities that
suggest like maybe the projection has
passed out when he loaded the film
wheels we start with an opening
narration from a security guard once
again reassuring us that the devil sucks
my mother's story would always begin the
same way with the suicide paving the way
for the devil's arrival and it would
always end with the deaths of all those
trapped and so when the financier of the
last airbender movie well you know the
main reason why people go back to
drinking
the Eagles resentment we think cuts a
detective having a cup of coffee with
his a a sponsor you may need to finally
start believing something greater than
yourself when I think about the guy that
killed my family I have a tough time
believing in much of anything oh god are
we and another Stephen King story I mean
the lead is a recovering drunk who will
partake in a lame supernatural
resolution it is pretty damn similar hey
got a good one for you
I'd like discover the truck that the man
cannonballed into earlier and try to
figure out what happened truck wasn't
here when he made impact must have
rolled you guys jump from that building
and white you're dead guy turn the
corner here these things have made the
bounce trucks off well thank God nobody
on a busy street reported a bread truck
with a dead guy embedded on it like
Wiley coyote with a driver who seems to
have disappeared off the face of the
earth rolling backwards into oncoming
traffic bouncing off cement blocks into
a parking lot of somebody's door you
just thought it was the bread truck with
a dead guy embedded I like wily coyote
with a driver who seems to have
disappeared off the face of the earth
rolling backwards into oncoming traffic
bouncing off cement blocks into a
parking lot of some guy's store man are
you not taking the stairs
Boyzone what are stuck in a ditch
just get on the damn elevator and I do
mean damned elevator sorry thanks for
help don't mention it
so let's do a checklist of our cliched
character awkward asshole
chef crabby old lady chef a black eye
check in there a good-looking woman with
Wilton no personality chef
generic good-looking guy with little to
no personality
oh that's missing is the spiritually
sensitive probably the devil come on
where's elevator six inspection mode huh
elevator 604 House to Queens three jacks
who says that you Dwight you got a
problem tell me about it I'm already up
on 35 fixing it the elevator yeah I'm
guessing either lightning struck it a
person jumped or spontaneously exploded
onto the street either way I don't think
it's worth calling the police over you
might want to secure that better okay
okay
the speakers are busted so only the
security team can talk to them and not
they to the security team this is
obvious jackass plenty of time to be an
obvious jackass well at least we got
tunes don't sing under that apple tree
with anyone else but me come on grandma
in other words anyone else but me hey
come on you try to make dialogue in a
Shyamalan film sound natural things
don't help when we find out our security
temp it's claustrophobic the maintenance
guy can't fix the problem and awkward to
make jerk-off still thinks he needs to
convince us that he can play a good
asshole can we get out of here
you're gonna need a good rest mattress
mania that's us now everybody's had
their mattress too long am i right you
didn't follow that advice about flip
every few months I also go door-to-door
selling cars life insurance in any
religion you're not a part of those do
it
have I mentioned I'm the obnoxious guy
you don't have to be as well-off as this
one I'm not that well of what makes me
good at selling mattresses is I can look
at a person's clothes and know exactly
how much they can afford to spend a new
lady your no super sleeper I've also
learned how to be as charming as a
cactus on your gallbladder but with that
said my humbleness interest you in a
mattress I'm the obnoxious guy the
lights start to flicker until it's
totally dark when they come back on they
see someone has bitten off a little bit
more than they could chew what in the
world feels like bitten so way the devil
bites people
it was an awkward phase
sometimes I try less seducing the lost
in wretched end just try fighting them
every once in a while you have issues
I'm the devil oh I think I get it
maybe instead the devil being the
traditional devil we always think of
maybe it was always this guy the entire
time oh my god okay we gotta call the
police so they only now call the cops
Dre and seeing how they know someone
jump on the building so you'd assume
they'd be there already and decide to
check out the seat hey three three
locust that's gonna be right around why
is it three three three instead of the
more obvious 666 well seeing how shallow
I don't like did the story maybe it just
counts for half evil so while they wait
for the cops
our hispanic guard thinks he saw
something in the video footage okay see
it that's just grain in the image that
you know it's a mistake it's like when
people see Jesus and then pancake or no
mr. mister thought oh my wait so the
devil shows off headshots in security
cameras it's not uncommon I have a
pretty profile you should have seen the
ones I use in the Paranormal Activity
movies
the lights go off again only this time a
mere breaks and wathah shards flies into
mr. askin to be fair he is going out
like his performance a pain in the
fucking mouth
6:02 we have a possible 187 I need
backup so of course there's only one
logical explanation for all of this you
must consider that one of those people
might be the devil really just like that
devil we're not leaving it open for more
plausible options like the Great Pumpkin
or the Flying Spaghetti Monster is this
guy for real where I come from we call
it the devil's meeting but what proof
does he have that the devil is near Oh
turn up the volume for this one maximize
the frame drop all your attention to the
screen close really get close this has
to be seen and heard with the utmost
clarity to be believed okay movie what's
your proof what are you doing oh when
he's in here
toast foes jelly side down yes you just
saw that the absolute proof to show that
the devil is near is taking a piece of
toast
putting jelly on it throwing it up in
the air and seeing if it lands jelly
side down with all due respect writers
creators makers of this movie did you
drink as a fetus I don't know how you
would accomplish that but it's the only
way I can comprehend writing this
spectacular ly stupid jelly side-down
equals devil are you fucking kidding me
is this the tested method one that's
really valuable is this the method the
Vatican uses do religious leaders all
come together to test the devil's
arrival with pastry goods
so in conclusion to our weekly kitchen
of demonic testing research we have
discovered that the cream in the coffee
has swirled in the right direction the
chocolate icing on the donut was equally
distributed and the mustard in the hand
sandwich on rye did not drip all the way
to the floor
all that remains of course is our
beloved toast test and seeing how we've
been doing this for 180 years and not
once has it ever landed on the wrong
side I think we can all get ready to go
while I perform this last one
fucking ridiculous actually to be fair
the jelly side-down test isn't a bad Oh
bullcrap Santa Christ do you have a
piece of toast with jelly on it of
course I do
I'm Santa Christ
best out of three oh now what oh sure
just because I'm the devil everyone
assumes I did it how do I know neither
of you dipped Nostalgia Critic you hate
the Power Rangers yeah but none of the
QIOs member myself oh it's Santa Christ
you fight monsters just for fun you
could be just as guilty can we do that
on Thursdays basic guys everybody this
elevators the suspect Hey people killing
one another in there yeah stop
okay okay what do you say we just finish
the review without any more metric okay
okay so the detective goes up to the
broken window deceived the jumper and
the killer and the elevator have any
connection the suicide note most of it
makes sense but then it ends with I can
hear the devil's for the steps drawn
here
usually suicide notes hurry they're all
crazy or all rational but this one's
both oh yeah just like that totally
crazy one I've read last week that said
duck duck orange juice Robert Downey jr.
or the totally rational one I came
across the other week that listed the
scientific and mathematical equations
about why the suicide happened mixing
the two never happens back on Lord of
the floors we see the lights go out
again leaving two more Mia so the devil
looks like a tp'ed version of Jack
Skellington it stares kids at birthday
parties and while the lights go out
it looks like grandma didn't want to
hang around anymore
I'll tell you those bells are gonna be
evacuating any time and I'm not gonna
want be in this elevator then so one of
the guards goes to see if he can fix the
wire the other two cops go searching for
more information on who the killer could
be leaving who to look after the
elevator that's right
crazy toast man of course oh yeah that's
a smart idea what the guy you declared
was insane in charge of a box of people
going insane and killing one another
that's like putting the Human Torch in
charge of keeping 50 bags of popcorn
kernels from popping you know
something's gonna blow oh come on
in this time of raging emotions and
uneasy nerves surely he won't do
anything to make it worse just to sell
them uh do you know how to get us here
oh that's just fucking great asshole
that'll totally calm him down why don't
you just pop in the CD playing let the
bodies hit the floor while you're at it
oh you don't know that maybe somebody
praying for their immortal souls will
make them
oh Christ why haven't we fired you yet
back away from each other now get off
we're gonna keep you safe and here's how
everyone get to a corner and place your
hands on the wall do it and whoever the
killer is really think about what you've
done well just shut up and keep your
hands on the wall so who do we turn to
to finally start making sense of all
this crazy toast man of course in a
hypothetical conversation that I'm not
really having how would this story of
yours end they all die
that's it yeah well let's wrap up here
man Hill welco Diablo says there's
nothing we can do but sir
what evidence do you have about the
toast landed Jilly side down Joey side
down they made the choices that brought
them here so the reason crazy toast man
thinks they're all gonna die is that
after doing more research it turns out
all of them have a criminal past so the
devil
obviously instead of killing them in an
unsuspicious quiet non camera recording
way decides to draw out the taking of
these random five people as slowly as
fucking possible and turn you took an
entire day and all this effort just to
take down five people who you could have
taken out in a millisecond I'm just
showing how secret and subtle I am
you're opposed secret and subtle as the
matrix anyone that clinically brain-dead
would be able to tell something was up
and are the really only five people in
the entire world going to hell today
really fucking five oh my god their
crimes range from bank fraud to
pickpocketing nobody else in the entire
world has done anything worse than this
look I just need a stupid day you know
how some companies have funny hat day or
casual clothes day I have stupid day
where I pick one day and don't do
anything that makes sense whatsoever
really bad at this shut up bowls of
oatmeal more frightening than him so
since the maintenance guy got axed off
as well because you know a building to
speak would only have one maintenance
guy one of the guards goes to see if he
can fix the elevator I might have found
the problem the bad wire looks like it
could be shorting out the circuits okay
why is it in movies all the important
wires and buttons that make everything
work are always put in rooms that have
no fucking lights don't you want to see
what you're doing when you're fiddling
with this incredibly important stuff
oh hey what is this button do oops
he sees one of the wires is caught and
caught in a puddle of water and rather
than go to the firefighters we clearly
establish have been here for some time
he tries to fix it himself well this
looks promising message for you though
it's comes as an especially tough blow
when they realize the husband of the
woman in the elevator might own the
security team of the building meaning
that the temp might be the killer
Sarah Carraway's husband doesn't own
Carraway security does he meet me in the
office now of course this could have
been an ingenious move in keeping the
audience guessing and on their toes
except for one simple fact that kind of
leads us to the conclusion that that's
probably not you cause your mommy
Davo you've constantly given away that a
killer is the devil how did you think
you were gonna fool us with this it's
like the Wolfman
trying to trick us that the killer in
the movie is fucking Dracula we kind of
know going in guys oh you mean he wasn't
the killer
this movie's totally keeping me guessing
so only two remain each one thinking
that the others the killer should kill
you right now
and will be your defense what a
predicament this is what he does he
wants us to get off will you shut up
crazy toast man I wanna do it according
to your story how would I save them
giving him attention hey come on
he's a good press agent yeah we're the
dumbest most inconsistent devil ever
just wouldn't try to say I'm trying to
say that I've seen games of risk with
faster strategies than yours yeah well
at least I'm still alive in this death
machine don't you like an Arctic King
tips up Santa Christ we all know miss
you is swear to God I will spill your
sweet juice although really all you do
is kill the devil that's such a bad
thing Rick be Pope you full of holes
okay okay look maybe the answers are the
rest of the movie perhaps we should
watch the rest of it maybe we can find
out what's going on I'm gonna put down
my gun you put down your candy spear
okay let's see what happens so to calm
the tude down the cop tells them a story
about how he almost lost himself to
alcoholism after his family died in a
hip and that they have a choice to do
the right thing and that works great for
about tuzik
just when it looks like it's revealed
who the killer is get a load of this so
the old lady is the devil how is that a
good twist
we were never made privy to the idea
that this was possible in the sixth
sense there were clues in a scenario
that made it clear the twist could
happen in this setup here they're just
making up the rules as they go and I
know what you're thinking oh well you
didn't predict it so it must be a good
twist
well I wouldn't be able to predict if
they all turn into Snowman of George
Takei but that doesn't mean it's good
it'd be more entertaining than this but
it definitely wouldn't be good are you
ready for your time the whores the liars
the Chiefs and the deserters it's always
the same thing why the hell is she
giving him a talking-to when she clearly
never did with any of the other victims
is the devil all this time really just
your angry mother trying to bawl you out
tech man Stan you think this will make
you good
maybe it's a random contrived way to
give this guy a chance to redeem himself
tada
I killed a mother and her son on
Bethlehem Pike five years ago you of
course confesses to the cop what else
that he was the guy who committed the
hit-and-run that killed the Cobbs family
you think you can be forgiven well
wouldn't you know it confessing his
crime wins him a get out of hell free
card and the devil lets him go leaving
god knows how much surveillance footage
fingerprints and testimonials that the
devil is the worst-kept immodesty
croteau world has ever known
my monitor now if you'll excuse me I am
off to go make what the Fox say a big
hint when she do
winder Boy George beauty check every
hair dye so long in town and of course
in the world of rushed whatever endings
the cup finds it in his heart to quite
instantly forgive the survivor I've been
waiting for this moment for five years
all the things I'd say to you I forgive
you you see my wife before she died told
me to swing away which prevented an
alien attack so I guess it kind of evens
things out
and sure enough a city is no longer
upside down but instead right-side up
ask me what it means ask me what the
means oh well the lease we got through
this movie together Santa Christ
my god the devil what's the devil you
know in hindsight the price you seen
that coming devil Shyamalan damn I shall
want even the reveal of yourself is a
leg twist where's the clues of who you
really were where's the deductive
reasoning I am still the master of twist
if you could think of a better one for
my movie I'd like to hear it
well how about a crazy toast guy was the
devil actually that's kind of brilliant
how the devil works he could do it all
without getting caught there's not a ton
of video footage of him prancing around
like a paparazzi or enough my only
weakness is critics like you pointing
out that I have any weaknesses prepare
to be shamah live
hello exact wait so the devil wasn't the
devil the devil was Santa Christ that
sounds it wasn't complicated can I steal
that I was waiting for him to reveal
himself so I could sent him back to hell
oh so you don't really do any that stuff
in the movie do you know that would be
unbelievably stupid thank God because
this movie makes no sense if it was just
a thriller about people stuck in an
elevator would have had a better chance
both of the actors are pretty decent
most of them and it has a fair grasp of
good pacing and cinematography but when
you throw in lame dialogue with plain
story elements and of course Elaine's
supernatural element that weakens the
suspense more than heightens it you get
a clumsy unfinished mess and it's
definitely one I'm glad to be done with
hey you folks all right in there it's
okay sweetie you can cut out the voice
now that was very narrow okay now why
don't you be a darling and lure us down
to the main floor
maybe okay it looks like Oh help me pry
open these doors will ya
this has a pool one two three jump
hahahaha everything's going according to
plan
people love Cthulhu
when he's near toast phones jelly side
down
you like games I don't care I'm plugging
a show about of
ceptin the concept it's a game within a
game that's right it's like that movie
platoon game ception the idea being they
create all new house rules for games you
already know that's making the new not
really but funny look at this colorful
cast of characters you got this nerd
this other nerd this chick who likes to
hit people with hair ye the camera off
his face just kid blind to the make
games for blind people if they thought
they sure this guy has no hair eyes
chest and yet the blind kid to scout go
down on them it's the classic games that
you know in new rules new people you
don't know with classic rules that went
nowhere but it's a cool concept with
cool people and pretty cool effects
seriously that title alone probably cost
a lot of money have to buy a kitten with
that money I'm gonna go buy a kitten you
watch game ception
rated R that's a lie it's not rated but
what do I care I'm gonna have a kitten
soon
somewhere in the Midwest a group of six
gamers decided to breathe new life into
their video games by creating new house
rules that had never been played before
these gamers are paw
Thomas Amanda
Sam
kind
and Rob though the concept of such an
endeavor was thought to be impossible
with most gamers having the attention
span of a goldfish
this group rose to the challenge to
successfully play games within games
thus creating the phenomenon of game
ception today on game ception we're
playing Call of Duty Michael Myers
Michael Myers works on any Call of Duty
but it plays best one in a modern
setting set up a free-for-all game with
one life in hardcore mode to disable the
radar one player is Michael Myers who
has to hunt all the victims the rest of
the players are victims who have to run
or hide from Michael the round is played
with only knives and smoke grenades and
nobody can kill Michael Myers unless
they're the last man standing whoever
dies first is the Michael Myers for next
round all right now let's start the hunt
I can only be one wife let's try that
again like killing you can keep this in
the video this is fun so I suggest
hiding because I'm gonna come find you
I'm gonna that's a good sign because I'm
gonna come exactly you understand
well there's somebody I'm gonna kill you
now hey what's up hey you're not allowed
to attack me ROM I said I'm supposed to
side there what do you have to run away
and hide
listen let's try this again but like
this is stupid oh you got look at you
know what I didn't seek only you die hey
can the last person know that's not fair
nevermind
Oh God who turned this song who turned
the why access to not in verdict hello
guest for it
you're gonna die I will find you
somebody's in here I've got a
particularly lack of skin nobody's in
here
where'd you go I see you now you can
kill that's not a smoke grenade run oh
it is I don't know what kind of grenades
I have there you on run run run
okay where'd you go no I really don't
like the city was scary
are you in the kitchen - no no oh that's
why I was in the hallway
oh I just ran it did you see that be
twitching into that wall - no I didn't
terrified right now I'm licking it I'm
so afraid my right past them deep all
right funny oh you didn't
where'd you go I ran away I will find
you Oh No but you automatically okay
Kyle's Mike Myers now no I really can
you soaked card smoke grenades nope
first to die
stop being such a pussy bitch run I
don't know respect worries one holy
bitch tits that was terrifying I just
saw you oh yeah this is really fuckin
dying all the time oh I was before oh my
gosh you get out of here your position
there buddy oh hi there buddy
no verify
alright I'm alive ok so I should
probably hide I know if that went where
I wanted it to go what play are you Paul
or for okay then I'm much more confident
well thank you thank you very much you
guys tonight any we're not gonna find
you that's what we start by the other
people and then we die a lot oh no not
me me at all I guess yeah you just kill
each other now where were you guys I'm
dead I didn't even know you were over
there I just shot out a window and it
was like oh I killed you Paul I'm sorry
Paul you should well that is definitely
not what you want to do you know it's
just you and her you're not being hunted
let's pretend for a moment I'm actually
not stuck I think he's on the plane
really did try to leave looking at the
ground which is making a lot harder to
find out where he is
runway you're behind him now there you
go
it'll be the clusterfuck around ready
people Bobby it's serious
no wonder you're in charge oh I chose a
good one who's behind me don't shoot me
oh you're it oh dang it oh that sucks
run run whoever that is player for you
know hey there's only one of you left
oh you're so screwed guys I was
literally chasing you I was literally
jumping down and you would jumped off
and turn the corner we should try that
one again what did you what happened is
you kicked you a joke game you ejected
the game hmm turn you touched her r2d2
Xbox with your foot nothing avoids way
to disrespect to class dude I hope that
noise was recorded dude Oh scared of
everyone
well there's so many of you this time Oh
where'd you go oh I jumped down in front
of you well I can put it in where your
pizza pans and stuff they're upstairs I
can put it in
are you screen cheating baby no screen
cheating I'm so hungry
um I never eat Meyers hungry where are
you see it's like it's frustrating
actually like really hiding first I saw
like all three of you all at once and
now you're all going I actually got one
of you you've come through here I see oh
so that was call of duty Michael Myers
thanks for subscribing and let us know
in the comments below a custom game we
should play next